I want to talk to you about all the
games you played because there are still
a bunch of big games coming in in 2016
you think it's over how's even started
yet peter brian your reviews editor so
you're all too aware of what's coming up
over the next two months just in case
you weren't prepared a fancy list of
some of the games that we should get
excited about how about all the games we
should accept mmm there's probably some
people who are excited about WWE 2k16
which is not on this list so I don't to
say it's a perfect list but it's a list
of some of the biggest job we say at
games coming out over the next two
months starting this week actually i'm
not even sure if this cat's not sure
this might be in that category tony hawk
pro skater 5 is out this friday said
this week not true it's not you're using
outdated information it's at wednesday
at the 29th 29 you're seeing the 25th
and i am dead they got pushed back I
don't know but rainy was talk to me the
other day and he had the 25th all I know
is coming up a 29 ok cool so next week
excited about that at all I'm interested
to see how what they're gonna do like if
they're going to try to mimic the old
style of gameplay completely or
introduce like new you know aspects to
the game that's going to really
determine how I feel about it because I
can go back and play old tony hawk games
right so if they really want to get me
excited I've got to do something with it
but I would like a little bit of that
classic flare it's itching and by the
trailers it looks like they're very much
leaning into the multiplayer sort of
party mode create parks and then share
them with your buddies kind of aspect of
it yeah be interesting to see how much
they lean into that but then I guess the
first sort of real big box game coming
out who would have thunk it the first of
two music playing games yeah back of the
band rock band 4 at october six and mike
you excited about yeah i haven't played
rock band since probably just three
what's that the last one come college
from you is very recently so that would
have been like what's yeah yeah there's
no me too i have class in like 10
minutes so let's hurry yeah i'm excited
about this i played both this and Guitar
Hero live at like preview events and
whatnot rock bands kind of new twist
they're putting the gameplay is like the
RPG progression in the career mode which
seems interesting enough to I mean I'm
just excited for these instrument bass
rhythm games to come back just to have
an excuse to
play them again yeah dust off the old
drums for so they've done a really good
job I think of making sure that like old
DLC and old peripherals work generally
across the board for this that brings me
to my question though both of you guys
like we may be excited for this game but
are you excited to have a bunch of
plastic instruments around your house
again like the guitars are pretty
innocuous like you can kind of you know
you can store them away relatively easy
this the drums that are a problem and
I've moved into a place that I'm on like
a second level so there's somebody's
sleeping underneath you're gonna make
friends real quick I know it's like a
master problem because I Stowe is like
having a couple drinks knee just gonna
lumpen on the drums for a while I
probably won't go down have to put that
girl over Matt's underneath them again
and of course yeah lies you said guitar
hero live coming out at just two weeks
later on october 20th any preference
Peter pretended to them I'm not really
big in these particular music games
mostly because i suck at them usually I
don't like games that it's like that but
I think they're great and I'm actually I
really like people who do enjoy these
games like play them because they get
really into it yeah so start of by proxy
I enjoy it but you know I kind of I
could go either way cool I have folks in
the chat in the comments I let us know
which one of those your much most
interested in HD collections of course
I've been a big thing this year again
uncharted the nathan drake collection
coming at October night I'm not too far
away excited about that one like yeah
I'm more excited I haven't played the
first one since I get released I forget
what year that was what I mean played 2
and everybody says to the best but I was
always one of those weird people who
enjoyed three more so I want to go back
and see if I was just drunk or like just
being stupid you were drunk well
actually no I would have been like again
I don't know how that wasn't it was came
out but yeah I always really enjoyed
three but two I think I didn't play
through in one sitting so I want to go
back and see if it really is just as
good as everyone says because again I
haven't seen it firsthand in a long time
but I'm sure this is a good primer for
um you know when for comes out yeah
that's what I feel it's a good way to
get ready again not to manage one I'm
not too many exclusives for ps4 while
coming up for the rest of the year so
that's the major at least one you can
you can get if you're a PlayStation
owner and next up october twenty third
it's that time of year again time to
play a new assassin's creed game
cinakisz i played it at an event couple
months ago and i was actually sort of
surprisingly
entertained by the sort of the sandbox
nature of some of those levels they've
done like the different sort of ways in
which you can tackle them sort of in
that like fun emerging way that like
Metal Gear Solid the way better bakes
you can sort of attacked it in any way
you want that like Assassin's Creed
games were very rigid for a long long
time super super boring and like just
too many missions of your tedious and
but yeah after playing that I felt a
little bit better about it have either
of you played any syndicate over the
past couple of months no but you've got
me interested now actually cuz the
things you're mentioning are gone our
problems I had of this series it's kind
of why I left it behind yeah a problem
they had to watch dogs as well and like
I've like been very vocal about how
irritated I've been with Assassin's
Creed for a couple of years so I'm kind
of like I'm really cautious optimistic
see and what our reviewer thinks about
it when it comes along and Mike you
played it at all over the past couple of
months yeah about a month ago I played
as EV so this is the first time that a
woman is one of the leading characters
and you know first on a console person I
go first on a console correct uh less
hasn't creed liberation I'm also head
mom for her name but yeah it's it was
she supposedly more stealth minded of
the two you can see Jacobs kind of just
mowing Jackie fools yeah and I think
he's getting the majority the story
missions but if you just want to explore
you can be easy as much as you can which
will be cool because I've always kind of
when you have the choice I've always
gravitated towards stealth and you know
metal gear solid 5 have been doing the
same thing and dishonor and I do the
same thing so I'd like to see if that
carries over well and makes syndicate
interesting enough for me to get back
into because Black Flag i really liked
but i haven't been that interested in
the franchise for a long time and I it's
too bad because I really liked it for
the first five yeah that's the problem
they sort of had was almost the problem
that happened with tomb raider were
eventually whoever got in control of the
game or got like mainstream and then
they just turned it into an action game
when it was never an action game to
begin with like saucers creed used to be
about spending a lot of lot of time
about killing one person and then
suddenly were just mowing down dozens
and dozens of folks yeah and on that
same day the legend of zelda triforce
heroes coming out on that hot nintendo
wii u peter you excited about that i am
excited i like zelda is a series that
just sort of warms my heart most part
you know i've liked pretty much every
game in the series and this one sort of
falls in
the same campus for swords so I'm i play
a little bit of III I enjoyed the aspect
of putting on different outfits it
changes your character and changes your
abilities and the interplay within a
team dynamic seems fun and interesting
it's not a mainline Zelda game but
that's okay cool something for the Wii U
as well after owners of that because
unfortunately of course we've had a
delay for starfox as well I think you
means something for the 3d assets I'm
sorry yes all right is there any gossip
I don't intend oh I know I don't know me
you I pay my way I like my way or my
remake is great buy one this holiday I
don't WWE 2k16 has his head's coming at
October 25th only two days after those
games yeah but that's also the same day
that halo 5 Guardians comes out Mike you
excited about that you big halo fan yeah
I am this is actually more excited I've
been for halo in a while I said bullets
there haven't been that many halos but
for came out at 2012 know what's been a
couple years yeah I was I mean the
master chief collection as a game is
great obviously did not have a great
launch but now that it's all for the
most part set i really enjoyed playing
through all those i did those recently
and then I did Spartan Ops that co-op
mode in Halo 4 that bridges the
campaign's between four and five
story-wise I just played halo 5 campaign
at a recent event I can't talk about it
yet but I hope preview up tomorrow
morning cool about the campaign you get
to play as fireteam Osiris which is a
sergeant Jameson Locke he's chasing down
master chief and blue team if you're
into halo lore they are Fred Kelly and
Linda you know way more about this i'm
assuming no yes i said i've read a lot
of the books and i don't know why you
don't usually get into laura i just
think it's pretty interesting sci fi a
lot of times a lot of the novels and
whatnot but essentially it's you know
the first game you're playing the very
first halo you think you're one of the
last you're the last spartan but it
turns out you're not a bunch survive
reach this from halo reach the battle
and it's really interesting because you
play as for different Spartans on both
teams and your kind of chasing down the
chief and it's calling into question
whether he's really a good person and a
hero ok which is interesting to me
because he's always been painted as this
you know he's bombastic and he's bold
and everything and he's always just
blowing up ships in outer space but he's
kind of been boring up until halo for
him and his relationship but maybe he's
a tool of an EVO
yeah and then there's something has
cypher yes we'll find out when ii get
halo 5 Guardians comes out on the
twenty-fifth and one thing I want to ask
both you guys November third do either
of you have the need Peter do you have
the need uh I like racing games like I'm
a casual racing Oh what what do you
think I'm talking about here need for
speed and Eve Smith coming you got the
need my mean don't think so the need no
subtitle I'll check it out need for
speed just need for speed resetting this
game franchise shooters excited about it
he's got the need I'm interest I'm
curious to see what they're gonna do
like that series began a long time ago
on PC and I loved it and over the years
I've just become so jaded with what
they've been doing like i loved the hot
pursuit stuff that was fun since then
I've just like I don't really see where
it fits in like the you know like the
landscape of racing games like why do I
really want to play this over you know
let's say the crew which I didn't love
but I still enjoyed forts of are the
four to six game a stuff yeah I mean
that looks wonderful like Gran Turismo I
actually really liked her in Turismo i
don'ts got a lot of problems but there's
something about those problems that are
endearing to me hmm so I just don't ya
we'll see i'm curious like i'm probably
gonna play a little bit of it this has
the full motion videos right yeah thats
looks pretty cool the guy from this is a
movie a lot of people probably have not
seen go for green street hooligans nope
made up oh wait laughter first yes it's
the west england vs mill wolf yeah and
there's a guy in it his name is Bower I
think and he's in rockford I oh yeah
Jack Bauer and then he voices okay a
snake yeah who also is gonna be in the
full motion videos for need for no I'm
just kids complete well I knew when I
moved to London the fry was living there
three days and I was overlooking the
West time it was like a bet half a mile
away the stadium and there was a fire
animus because Millwall fans had set a
car on fire yeah good so that's a need
for speed actually the one thing i like
about need to speed are the one thing
that's really interesting in me is the
entire game gets played over the course
of one night all those f of these
happened one night that's right yeah
endless light in this game no daylight
yep i remember hearing that
King what yeah we're a global comedy
take that ya blew my mind I'm really
into it um a couple of days after that
november six called a duty time black
ops 3 uh collar defense either of you I
like the campaign's none either fun each
other pair a little bit yeah not I'm
dying for it but I'll give it a shot
yeah the trailer campaigns always kind
of delivery as far as the first black
ops was pretty refreshing is yeah
definitely that's psychological stuff
and then the JFK conspiracy theories and
we played a lot of black ops 3 the beta
on ps4 and xbox one you know Eric Tang
Chris waters gotten a lot into it Rob
handlery had perfected that glitch
ability because you know the multiplayer
they have those um the specialist
classes now that can you can kind of do
these super abilities and like you might
in destiny yeah they're doing an
overwatch or a right or in every FPS
coming out next year yeah the battleborn
yeah it's the way of things i'll cry so
excited about the multiplayer Peter
you're excited about the single-player
stuff yeah yeah looks like a strong
enough package I guess we'll know soon
enough for call duty funds and November
as six that comes out four days before
maybe the biggest day on the video game
year so many games coming out that one
day so many games coming at that one day
but the one everyone wants to talk about
right off the bag at rodea the sky
Ranger coming out for Wii U and 3ds Yuji
naka is a genius finally making its way
to North America you know what's crazy
is the wii u version of that game it
comes packaged with a wii version of the
game that isn't a port it's a totally
different reimagining of the game what
yeah it's like two games in one he's
reimagining a game that just released
the same well no the wee one was
finished like a long time ago and then
they came back and they finished the wii
u version after it's not just like
upgraded visuals like they've changed
her nasty ex of the gameplay like i know
i didn't expect you to notice much about
right there Peter November 10 knock as a
genius get you get your pre-orders in
make sure that November 10th you're not
the one waiting in line do you have it
do you have heard it now we're so there
damn it if that does happen there are a
couple of our games coming at that day
fallout 4 rise of the Tomb Raider and
starcraft 2 legacy the void Never let's
start with fallout 4 first of all my
goodness if i wasn't working in video
games I'd be taking a month off this is
like this is gonna be so much fun Pete
are you excited for for the the fourth
okay I am I am it's been a long time
since I played fallout 3 but I really
like that and I'm really excited to see
that some of the soft guys have
contributed to the shooting aspect to
this game which we all know now is like
way better than three that system is no
longer a crutch for that broken shooty
shooty bangbang stuff so no yeah I'm
really excited and as someone who really
enjoyed metal gear and the way that it's
open world functioned I know it's very
different from the way fall at fours
works but I'm very curious to to see how
it impresses me because I'm sure it will
and I'm sure that'll also change you
know my opinion a bit on what was great
or maybe not so great about metal gear
and that's always really fun i think is
having your your thoughts and opinions
challenged and learning new stuff and I
think fell out for is a great
opportunity for all of that yeah I've
Devon back into a 493 and I was doing a
bunch of like stuff I hadn't done before
like creating new weapons and you know
like using the the the bridge know that
whatever the sheets you schematics you
get and then I was looking back at the
traders 44 lat foreign that you can
build your own weapons out of like
anything you want there's gonna be so
much depth to this and really exciting
and it's been five years since New Vegas
so you know that's a lot of its gonna
feel like a much more different than
fall that game hopefully yeah Mike what
you take either one of these tomb raider
or Starcraft which was like I really not
it I'm a big star craft fan yeah i'm
looking forward to that but i think
that's one of those games i'll be
playing throughout the next year rice
okay and rise a tomb raider i'm really
excited for it doesn't fall as high on
my priority list as fallout 4 but both
starcraft and the rise of tomb raider
both look great on rise of the Tomb
Raider I'm excited to see where they
take Laura now because obviously the
first Tomb Raider reboot 2013 yeah
awesome I liked it a lot and I think
they did a great job of characterizing
her is more than just this action hero
my worry is that the trailer the
gameplay trailer they put ad shows her
again just like straight up murdering
dozens of people which just seems like
like as fun is the last tomb raider was
it's just like I played that game trying
not to kill people
because it just seemed like a kind of
too easy and be just not in the spirit
of Tomb Raider like an feel like like
she's just ridiculously op4 some you
know she's not wearing armor you know
it's kind of crazy at some stages and
also in that last tomb raider it was
just these like a band of pirates from
what i remember but now these guys look
like some yeah they'll get a military
yeah mercenaries so i guess we'll find
out yeah the looking forward to that
when of course coming out and all that
xbox one exclusivity nonsense on
november 10 as starcraft 2 as well
interesting to think that this is the i
guess the third this is the end of their
trilogy which started again five years
ago and it's crazy to think that likes
that the starcraft 2 community is a
completely different beast thought it
was five years ago to what I was four
years ago like even two years ago like
at this stage it's almost like they're
releasing a game for a community that's
moved on to two different competitive
games and you know like i'm mostly
looking forward to playing it so i can
enjoy the single player stuff but yeah
it's going to be reduced you can see
what the receptionist of course that's
coming at around the time at blizzcon as
well so maybe maybe there'll be a bit
more excitement around us come November
time and November 26th we're not done
yet TrackMania turbo is coming out whoo
yeah hey Chuck many of fans here no not
really it's a I played on VR did you do
the viewer thing why would I it's like
the one game you should never play in VR
exactly it's like oh my god this is
amazing but it's impossible to turn you
it's like a it's like a discipline and
you know VR is like you put on the
headset and it's all about like moving
around the space and moving your head
never done it trackmania is like a
discipline and keeping your head it's
like tight as possible because you're
like driving into corners and it's all
about like these little twitch driving
controls of eternal event like you're
done in Dustin it's just one of those
experiences is not meant for VR no and I
don't understand why people try to
shoehorn it in there cuz any dumb in
case I need a crush I just need a crutch
no no it's a great game I love
trackmania cool no I very well could be
a great game but v are for that no maybe
not we'll see maybe if hey that if
that's what Morpheus ends up being just
a weird like additive modes to other
games then I'm not so sure but I love it
aesthetic looks cool there's this crazy
double driver mode where both of you are
driving the car at the same time
close like drivers in yeah yeah
basically except both of your driving
not one of you at a time which is pretty
good load wait you didn't have the
person in the car that had like the
brakes they could apply at any moment
dude I like drove in Ireland for like
two years at a real license it's a whole
different world don't even worry about
it remember 26 for TrackMania turbo yeah
december first two more bangers coming
out let's start first of all with the
over a little bit the other Avalanche
open-world game just calls three you
were a massive fan of Mad Max decent
enough game more excited for Just Cause
3 yeah like I think there was a few
things in Mad Max that were wonderful
just didn't capitalize on those what
I've played up just cause the things
that are really great are the things
you're doing moment to moment all the
time like moving blowing stuff up
getting from one spot to another like
gliding through the air like all of
those feel really good and I really
liked all of that so I'm much more
optimistic for this and Mad Max doesn't
look at your standing underneath the
helicopter boots mad max hasn't you know
dis Muk dissuaded me from Avalanche as a
whole it was made by a different team
like countries apart anyway but yet this
game just looks fantastic so I mean
we'll see yeah look forward to a hidden
December first the same day as Rainbow
six siege and we play a lot of us here
in the office sure there's a bunch of
stuff coming up this week I think about
remember succeeds as well and I'm not
sure how much we talked about so I can't
talk about any of it but come back to
gamespot com for that and are you guys
excited about it at all it seems like
sort of hyper andis is sort of waned off
a little bit cuz they're beating so many
betas I just feel like they've been
making like spin-offs to Rainbow six
forever what are they gonna come out
with rainbow seven odd ah the doors that
way oh you making my puns look good I
want ding chavez back you can't have a
radio six game but had some hot date
tonio mabini he was my number two oh
really no one knows who he is but I Tony
mldg he was also agreements no yeah you
did he was Italian I think well gee I
hope so yeah risen Impostors the
explosive specialist and Rainbow six
rogue spear well yeah the first one I
ever played that was great that I've got
into him yeah rogue spear was a game
that successfully anticipated an actual
[ __ ] the most
asian georgia oh yeah that literally
happened four years later there's a
level when you're like into blitzie like
shooting tanks and then there was like
footage of happening a couple years
later Tom Clancy yeah is the in currency
kuwaiti the intro to rogue spear was an
actual they were trying to do one of
those news montage yes and it was
startlingly realistic for someone like
of my age yeah or art but we were first
Christmas one year yeah yeah and then
all that stuff started happening yes
there's like old a show cuz the dudes
fall real realistically and so it's like
watching black mirror and then I noticed
a prime minister boxes gentleman's junk
in a pig's neck em anyway none of that
is in rainbow six siege but that's
coming at the summer first if you're
interested and then the last game is
coming at this year what a year 2015 for
video games let's finish it off with
just a cherry on top the US release of
Devil's third coming december 11 has it
go with that Wii U game whoo what about
Xenoblade Chronicles X yeah I guess
that's going into my peen Xena bed
chronicles grace Devil's third dough
garbage ha ha three out of ten the
beginning we got a 10 3 to 10 released
in europe look at this look at that whoa
we just disappeared european players
have been quote unquote enjoying this
for the past six months or so it's set
in japan as well of course but yet the
US release coming december 11th so make
sure you save all those gamestop
vouchers you got for christmas so you
can pick this bad boy up in the new year
and that's all the games coming out
before we finish Mike mahadi pick one
favorite game most anticipated game
coming out between now and Jesus time
2015 fallout 4 all right Peter Brown
call it for it's a 3 hate to be lame
it's it kind of a tie between fall and
zuly chronicles like yeah and devil
start won't I know what I'm getting
myself into the other one I'm like what
is inside of this a massive game so
we'll see which what I'm talking about
you don't know but also close second is
blood boards expansion oh yeah i'm
curious about battlefront just because i
have some mmm i'm curious to see how
it's going to turn out because i've been
we've been hearing good things been
hearing things that make me hesitate but
we'll see yeah bunch of great games
coming out this year and many we talked
about now many we didn't so let us know
in the comments what your favorite game
is coming out between now and the
number thirty first and also what you
think is going to be Game of the Year
2015 because it is a absolutely crazy
here for video games yeah rocket League
yeah who knows so see about that let us
know in the comments